now we turn to election Politics the
Republican Presidential field is growing
with some notable names joining the race
on Wednesday we expect Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis to announce the start of
his campaign South Carolina Senator Tim
Scott filed his campaign paperwork on
Friday and will appear at a kickoff
rally today in North Charleston Robert
Costa is there with more on the primary
campaign Bob good morning
good morning Nate the Republican
presidential race it's entering a new
phase an expanding field as those
debates Loom on the horizon the latest
entry Senator Tim Scott of South
Carolina who's positioning himself as a
consistent conservative who has deep
ties to the Evangelical Christian
Community
you can't get an amen Senator Tim Scott
has been testing the presidential waters
for weeks in the early primary States we
have to start teaching the necessity of
individual responsibility now his
campaign has bought nearly 6 million
dollars in ads to air in Iowa and New
Hampshire as he returns as a candidate
in the coming days Scott has shown
little eagerness to take on Donald Trump
directly explaining to CBS News last
month his take on the race I see that
America is starving for positive
optimistic leadership I want to provide
that alternative but recent CBS News
polling shows likely GOP Primary voters
are looking for a candidate who digs
into the culture wars and makes liberals
angry that same poll shows Scott with
just one percent support while former
president Trump leads overwhelmingly and
Florida Governor Ronda santis comes in
second with 22 percent
DeSantis is expected to officially join
the race this week after recent events
outside of Florida where he pushed his
conservative agenda
and kiss babies in New Hampshire a
DeSantis Ally tells CBS News the
governor privately told his biggest
donors last week that he is the only
Republican who can win a general
election his latest shot at Trump's
electability I think the party has
developed a culture of losing I think
that there's uh not uh accountability
but former president Trump and his top
advisers remain increasingly confident
Donald Trump Paul Molina's CNN Town Hall
earlier this month which they believe
solidified his standing let's just win
it again and straighten out our country
and most Republican house members from
Florida have already endorsed Trump over
DeSantis to me it's not really about
Donald Trump versus Ron DeSantis it's
about what America needs we need
somebody who can step in day one look at
Vladimir Putin look at Gigi ping and say
okay enough
I'm back on the endorsement front
Senator John thune of South Dakota the
Senate's number two Republican is
throwing his support behind Senator
Scott and will be here in North
Charleston this morning sources tell us
that Senator Scott and others are
getting into the race now because they
want to make sure they have enough time
to build support before that first
debate in August Tony
all right Bob that Jonathan endorsement
is something uh civility though I don't
know if the base of the Republican party
wants it that poll was interesting
they're looking for a candidate that
makes the other side angry notable stuff
there appreciate it I know you'll have
much more on it